I promise you the president has a big
stick
hi I'm Nicolas be with recent TV and
today we're talking with the veteran
newsmen Jules whit cover he's the author
most recently of the American vice
presidency from irrelevance to power
Jules wit covered thanks for talking to
thank you how did the vice presidency go
from being irrelevant or a joke to being
very powerful and still kind of a joke
but much more important it was a very
slow process because for most most
presidents they didn't either
know their vice presidents or care much
about them or disagree with them and and
they didn't feel they that they needed
they didn't give them anything to do
I think determine the the wake up came
in 1945 when Truman replaced the FDR
without being told about the atomic bomb
and so I think after that presidents
realizes they had at least keep their
vice presidents at fault what was going
on but was another thirty years after
that before a president really brought a
vice president in as a governing partner
that was Jimmy Carter with Walter
Mondale and the reason he he were the
reasons he did it was the previous
Democratic nominee sure George George
McGovern had a disastrous choice of his
vice president who turned out to be
unsuitable according to public opinion
and that was top position because he had
some like some shock treatments so
Carter caught a river dad decided he was
going to thoroughly vet his prospects
for Vice President
and obviously that worked at least in 76
because Carter the Carter Mondale ticket
won
what's that considered a good experiment
though because you know they did not get
reelected what it was considered a very
good experiment because of what was done
was called up the Mondale model because
Mondale before going down to be
interviewed by Carter
instead of Al or memorandum which he
listed the things that he thought Carter
needed as a vice president and things
that Mondale could
so pretty much after that with some
exceptions every presidential nominee
well most presidential nominees have
followed that that model of vetting the
person they wanted in terms of what
whether they could perform useful
services as a vice president so then how
does that explain three terms later you
have the bizarre and disastrous pic of
Dan Quayle senator you're no Jack
Kennedy I can't explain it particularly
because you remember that the CD of
George Bush became vice president at a
month or two months later he always
became president himself because Ronald
Reagan was almost assassinated so one of
the thought would have thought that
would been foremost in his mind but for
a reason it wasn't I've been told that
one of the reasons he picked Quayle was
that his his advisor at the time Roger
Ailes the TV advisor said make your own
choice because you're too much been
considering a lap dog to Ronald Reagan
be your own man so he became still man
and became a one-term president
obviously but then Clinton and in his
pick of Al Gore I talked a little bit
about that because that also seems to be
a real shift where you had to and I
guess it goes back to kind of Carter
Amanda to people who are kind of the
same age of the same generation and they
presented a real united front but it
really was it was a shift in the sense
that they both came from the south and
so but it would turn out to be an
excellent partnership for the campaign
because a core kind of came out of his
shell turned out to be very humorous
believe it or not from his reputation
but when when the two of them traveled
together which I I accompanied them on
the campaign they were hilarious and
they actually bought bonded and and it
got to be a real partnership and what
are the differences though from the
Mondale model was that Gore was given
specific areas of responsibility things
that he was interested in like the
environment and science policy things
like that yeah but then that
relationship soured in the wake of the
Clinton scandals in the second term and
because and Clinton was either not
capable
or wasn't able to war wasn't asked to
campaign very she wasn't asked to
campaign or a much Gore tried to put the
difference between Clinton himself and
think maybe that's the reason he lost
because he couldn't even campaign on the
on the strong suits of the Clinton
administration because personal
relationship had soured so well you know
we talk a lot about the negative side or
most of us about the negative side of
the imperial presidency is there a kind
of imperial vice presidency as well
certainly that's the way that a lot of
people talked about Dick Cheney under
George Bush that and Cheney was brains
Bush's brain he was running the show
he's Darth Vader do you would you buy
that well I do think it was it was
always overdone it was interesting from
the beginning that JD was asked but by
the presidential nominee to pick pick
his voice but he wouldn't he was part of
the search committee essentially pricked
to pick himself
yeah what are the what are the people
and and the Bush campaign said I said to
be when I asked him about it he said
that JD had walked through an open door
I tell you you know the other probably
the most controversial the vice
presidential nominee of the past few a
couple of times is Sarah Palin was that
done kind of in desperation absolutely
yes so that was just were behind in the
polls we got to do something McCain had
only met her once fleetingly didn't know
much about her it was a Hail Mary pass
and you can actually see Russia from
land here in Alaska and although she
turned out to be a very cherished
charismatic candidate and a lot of
people liked her she certainly did doing
it do him any good well then who is your
favorite vice president there's been 47
vice presidents who's your favorite well
I like Mondale personally and I like to
I like the way for her function to
function in the vice presidency who is
the worst vice president in history
according to your lights well I think I
can aqualified legal basis is an illegal
basis and it was interesting that Agnew
was picked by you by Nixon because he
was strong on law and order but when he
got him when he got in the office he
wanted to be part of the he wanted to be
part of the administration and and the
Nixon insiders
ready to hold him and just completely
shut him out I've always said that that
you couldn't couldn't program
Agnew to leave a burning building so
they just had a low estimation of his
abilities or his smarts or was it
something all both that's what it was at
plus they didn't they didn't want it to
be in the line of succession to the
presidency and in fact once before they
second term they tried to thought about
ducking it dumping Agnew and one of the
things that Nixon proposed believe it or
not was putting him on a Supreme Court
well I wouldn't work that would have
helped his legal problem well we'll
leave it there thank you so much we've
been talking with Jules Witte cover he's
the author most recently of the American
vice presidency from irrelevance to
power Thank You Jules welcome very much
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you